(mellow electronic music)
- [Narrator] Shanghai is
home to one of the world's
richest collections of Art Deco buildings.
The city's signature style saw
its heyday in the 1930s
and epitomized luxury.
It grew increasingly popular with
the rise of cinema and Hollywood films,
sparking a widespread hunger for the same
glamorous buildings moviegoers
saw on the silver screen.
- [Announcer] This Great Big
Story was made possible by
Fairmont, an Accor Hotel experience.
(mellow electronic music)
- [Narrator] Art Deco is
a style of visual arts
that influenced everything from
architecture to everyday objects.
Its trademarks are geometric forms,
linear shapes and narrow windows.
A great example is the Grand Theatre.
Built in 1928, the Theatre was
frequented by Shanghai's glitterati,
and features a sophisticated combination
of modernist and traditional elements.
The Theatre boasts a beautiful
modernist Art Deco facade
with its stern horizontal
and vertical lines.
Meanwhile, its classical
red and gold interiors
are reminiscent of styles
from Rome or Florence.
One of the most notorious buildings from
this golden age of
cinema is the Paramount.
Built in 1933, it was the most
glamorous ballroom in town,
and a favorite gathering for
starlets, tycoons, and gangsters.
Its huge circular tower, with
its avant-garde lighting,
was an ambitious and revolutionary
design element at the time,
pushing the traditional architectural
boundaries of 1930’s Shanghai.
Today, Shanghai is widely known
for its futuristic skyline;
but nestled in between
is a trove of treasures
of the world's finest
examples of Art Deco.
(chiming electronic note)